[Music]
in horrible person news I like people at
a horrible baby-talking shame in my eyes
my mouth was still moving I said we knew
a few that's not what you said at all
but I think it's very dry we thought no
no we knew Abdullah died I see and this
was submitted by albino paper me an
obese airline airplane passenger forced
a flight attendant to wipe his butt why
saw this circulating trauma I read it
it's traumatizing for the flight
attendant now I haven't heard this story
me neither right yeah but I did mention
this before the particles that we were
doing the other day where I was on a
flight in Miami yeah and there were two
large people that were a couple and they
were so big that they had to get three
seats to fit both of them yeah and they
smelled like [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and I could
not sleep for five hours on the flight
because it smelled like [ __ ]
so bad like I couldn't so I like a
[ __ ] window seats so I can lean back
and lean against the wall so I could
knock out I couldn't do it because the
smell was so bad I can so I kind of
understand that because it was me I had
to go to that the people in front of me
had to go through it so I don't even
want to know what the people behind them
near the ass had to go through that's
what I was thinking for this situation
like this guy he can't even reach so he
knows how like mud but he has so he's
like hey a flight attendant I have mud
butt and it smells really bad right now
and I don't want people to throw up can
you help me help everyone else I saw I
was thinking
Bart this is a horrible person remember
the word forced was Oh
they forced ya so because of my reason
or many reasons but I fly with a mask
because I have smelled some funky asking
the mask helps you it helps well unless
that mask had holy water and the Pope
blessed it I would have helped I was
going to [ __ ] die dude I don't chew
gum and I'll have the mass I could smell
my minty breath also your hotbox the
mask
although so like I mean what do you say
in that situation right you think yeah
hey you [ __ ] smell or even if I said
it nicely what can they do about it it's
already maybe the bathroom like wipe
he'll think they could fit we know
smelly people and a shower won't help
them oh no wait bro so let me tell you
this [ __ ] up story so there were a
crew of female flight attendants in
Taiwan they were holding this press
conference and they were saying how they
were left physically and mentally
traumatized after complying with the
demands of this obese American passenger
so they were flying looks like a [ __ ]
gross walrus - it bums me out that he's
American I thought he was gonna be in
there again but I was like please please
forum it just once LA to Taipei Thursday
is about 440 pounds I love how they took
a picture of his ass - Luisi he's the
worst look at he actually doesn't like a
walrus that was not even a joke oh yeah
yeah legit looks like a lot looks like a
fat walrus it's a back in here taking
Chomper right there the couple same size
of that but two of them 400 pounds is
too much man yeah yeah they couldn't
they had to buy three seats to fit both
of them well this one person set with
three seats can we have a smell ohmmeter
for like passengers and if you if you
passed a certain limit you can like
cologne too
have a smell meter it's like you [ __ ]
stink
you cannot come on this airplane I think
on airplanes too they said you you can't
spray like an obscene set off the alarm
I don't know what it is but they said
you can't do it yet there's like a sign
I don't read she can't be she can't read
this place you know that explains so
much because sometimes I'll be texting
her and she responds back with some he
had nothing to do with anything
hey what are you doing good not even
that hungry thank you okay so let me
keep telling you so he he we boarded the
plane on a wheelchair he asked to be
placed on a row with three free seats
then he asked for help to go to the
bathroom um so he was explaining that he
recently had surgery on his hand he did
not fit in the economy class bathroom so
he was escorted to the business class
one and the smell he's soon press the
emergency assistant button calling for a
flight attendant inside to pull his
underwear down then the flight crew
these Taiwanese people are because they
know they were and they were made the
entire crew was all female so there was
no male to like us this year yeah so he
insisted and pleaded and threatened to
relieve himself on the floor if oh my
god sure how you be more Chinese than
Chinese people but they're Thai one
Chinese deeply yes sir then are you just
offended so many people I don't care
dude he's Taiwanese and I [ __ ] myself
every day so then the flight attendant
tried to use a blanket to cover the
man's exposed genitals because see is
generally he slapped it away
oh damn she put on a pair of surgical
gloves to pull down his underwear he's
like I need everybody to see and then so
she was gonna close the door but then he
insisted that the bathroom door be kept
open clearly when it witness me oh my
god he might he might be some weird like
he's
likes to expose himself kind of guy so
at least that request was denied it did
close first where you said that he was
in a wheelchair I was gonna be like
minorly sympathetic I was like okay is
he like disabled to a point where he
like he can't do anything and maybe but
sorry I probably could walk and he just
wanted someone to push him around Orson
yeah so that's all bad right but the
worst part here he's P is so then he
started calling the flight attendant to
come inside again and to wipe his ass
for you oh so then the crate carry hell
no and then the man was like okay then
I'm gonna stay in this bathroom for the
entire flight and so that would
obviously inconvenience the business
class passengers then it's also not safe
and so she she just felt like she had no
choice oh myself has put on three layers
of gloves gym that woman a trophy and a
million dollars I think she started
wiping and this [ __ ] started
moaning and pleasure nothing deeper and
deeper oh [ __ ]
so then he claimed that she hadn't done
a good enough job and made her wipe
three more times before he was he was
getting [ __ ] anal pleasure I think
this guy was stopping by Taiwan to go to
Thailand to go [ __ ] something yeah this
this seems like that kind of day I wish
she would have poured some aftershave on
his [ __ ] I would have gone in the
[ __ ] thought the [ __ ] but shit's not
there anymore but I would have [ __ ]
with the three layers of [ __ ] I would
have gone and smeared it on his [ __ ]
me hell yeah
passengers you're gonna smell [ __ ] pad
on your guys while his [ __ ] while his
[ __ ] Jabba the Hutt [ __ ] ass is on
that game I would just start unloading
elbows and Fitz is right as his [ __ ]
face dude what you can't move this poor
woman so then after she lost herself
inside the bathroom and then she was
crying and vomiting and she was anywhere
that's crazy huh she took it for the
team yes
be able to wash away the entropy [ __ ]
for a raise so this was on EVA Air oh my
mom's old company gasps aw she was
calling so in her post where she
described this whole experience she was
calling on EVA Air to better protect its
employees yeah flight attendants and to
prevent similar physically challenged
passengers from boarding crying the
other bathroom too I would cry more than
it's still traumatising whether poor
lady look at her look at this like look
at the trauma it looks like she what the
hell in back dude okay that's a real
bummer right between the [ __ ] out of
this man's ass like he's an [ __ ] dude
there should be restrictions though like
it's not even like discriminatory at
this point right it's just if you can't
wipe your own ass you shouldn't be
flying
yes but just don't you can't go alone
like if you have physical needs cheap
ass [ __ ] cleaners that's not the
flight attendants mic that's not on
their [ __ ] job title like white
people's ass yeah air did say no I'm
agreeing with you that EVA Air did say
that the flight attendants are not
obligated to act upon the demands of
passengers even if they require special
assistance because that's a huge
liability for the company for sure but
this [ __ ] man like put yourself
in your shoes like he totally cornered
her and how does he have money to travel
see that's what government assistance
yeah so he just saves up all that money
he travels to the other countries and he
probably just buys people all the time
and aside from his you know obviously
like terrible demeanor as a human being
he's [ __ ] trash you know from
somebody who will he look like hundred
and sixty-five pounds right like I can't
look at somebody being overweight as a
disability that I feel bad for you about
that's something that you did to
yourself that was a choice that is a
choice a disability that happened
because you of a
you know I mean of abundance of food
nutrients whatever the [ __ ] that it is
that it's something that you chose to do
right and now people have to pay for
your choice to be that unhealthy people
got to wipe your ass because you are
greedy yeah like what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that that's why in Japan if
you're a sumo wrestler you're not ever
allowed to ride the subway station
because it's your choice to be that big
that's fine don't inconvenience the rest
of society yeah every day all right uh
buses and taxis and stuff or like yeah
but it's like a collective mindset but
out here you know they'll they'll
consider that like fat shaming or like
yeah being I mean it's it's a fine line
right because out there they don't have
many acts there's not much access for
people in wheelchairs and stuff like
that and they feel embarrassed and also
a burden to society for being disabled
so it's it's kind of like where do you I
don't know it's because I know that side
about Japan where it's like you know if
you are if you're it's life kind of does
suck if you don't have legs or like if
you're in a wheelchair because there's
not many places you can go you kind of
stuck at home all day well then it's the
same thing is like we are too
accommodating then you have these
entitled [ __ ] like this and then you
have con artists that are disabled and
they go into businesses and things and
they go oh this isn't a DEA compliant so
I'm gonna sue you you know like there's
there's all that [ __ ] to happen to that
guy they should just drop him off in the
middle of the ocean it's technically
illegal I mean you should feed him to a
cannibalistic tribe he was moaning
absolutely horrible but I mean okay got
it yeah yeah not saying I wasn't
horrible I'm just like what would they
get him on legally get him on something
if you guys ever gone EVA Air they have
the best preflight music it's so
peaceful they play this like a little
tower nice traditional folk song that
would be nice playing doughball your
wife in his ass you know I like your lie
though is you're gonna associated with
that Coriana no there's only one Korean
air yeah Carina
yeah that one they play really nice
music to their classical music and
flight attendants are the [ __ ] do they
look like they're from the future thumbs
the outfits they got a little blue scarf
like this it's time they're so [ __ ]
sweet and they're very very very very
pretty I hope this guy doesn't come back
into the country I hope you guys just
dropped off back at home in the ocean
you [ __ ] whale his PR this little
ocean will clean his ass yeah pouring
salt that Anton will just eat his
[ __ ] for him you son of a [ __ ]
you
[Music]